we mentioned that the president is
trailing here in pennsylvania and that
has been true
for months now and tonight he's going to
get some added help former president
obama will hit the campaign trail
in person for the first time in
philadelphia and that's where we find
our ed o'keefe today ed good morning to
you i was wondering when we might see
the former president you're going to see
him tonight tony this is a reminder of
how important pennsylvania is to both
campaigns the president
was where you are last night former
president obama makes his pandemic
campaign trail debut
tonight here in philadelphia he'll hold
what the biting campaign calls
a drive-through rally supporters show up
in their vehicles and honk and approval
instead of applaud they'll address them
on the parking lots of the philadelphia
eagles
stadium it's a reminder that swing
states like this one
are going to figure out who wins the
white house
you know we win pennsylvania we win the
whole thing
pennsylvania's 20 electoral votes are
critical to the president's reelection
the latest cbs news battleground tracker
shows him trailing democratic rival joe
biden
in a state mr trump won four years ago
by about 44 thousand votes
hello erie may i please have your vote
he went back to erie in the northwestern
industrial corner of the state
because it helped him win four years ago
it's been a mostly democratic area
until he flipped it red in 2016.
the president knows that one way to
attack biden in this part of the country
is to raise questions about his stance
on hydraulic fracking
joe biden will ban fracking
and abolish pennsylvania energy
biden has said he opposes new fracking
on federal land
no matter how many lies he tells i am
not
not not banning frackie while the former
vice president remains off the campaign
trail preparing for thursday night's
debate in nashville
his running mate kamala harris is
filling the void holding a virtual rally
with supporters
in wisconsin wisconsin you're the key
milwaukee we need you and tonight former
president barack obama is set to hold
his first in-person campaign event for
biden
in philadelphia joe biden needs your
vote
he spent the last several months urging
biden supporters to register to vote
and is expected to make several
in-person appearances in the closing
days
of the campaign
in another sign of the advantage the
binding campaign has they reported last
night
having three times as much campaign
money in the bank than the trump
campaign
now the president's team does a lot of
its spending in cooperation with the
republican national committee
but it's a reminder that in these
closing days the binding campaign is
going to be able to unload
millions of dollars in advertising and
get out the vote efforts with
how many days left tony you have an rv
i brought the sign 13 days to go
13 days i can read that loud and clear
ed thank you very much but i do have a
question there i'm not sure if that is a
white board or a magic white board if it
were magic perhaps you could let us know
when we might get final results in
pennsylvania because i know we have that
court ruling that says now they're going
to be counting
three days after mail-in ballots as long
as they're postmarked by election day
that's right so election day could turn
into election week
election weeks we'll see
yeah and that is an important reminder
for our viewers we're going to have to
be patient
two weeks from today when we start
talking about results ed thank you very
much
gail anthony as i send it back to you we
are two weeks from election day which
means tomorrow morning
we will be two weeks from coverage of
that vote
coming in and we do really have to
underscore for people
you're probably not going to know in a
state like pennsylvania on election
morning the day after
such an important point i think we need
to keep pointing that out
frequently leading up to election day
and it doesn't make the
the election not legitimate because we
don't have a result
the night that we expect to so many
people voting early exactly
the record numbers and some very big
numbers on the o'keefe calendar which we
will keep watching every day tony thanks